[تصفيق]
ايو من
الصبح من الصبح يشرب والله من الصبح لع
ميه يشرب من الصبح ولا واحد ق شربه لا في
السب كانت في ميه ولا في المدارس في ميه
ولا فيدور في ميه ولا بنام ولا بنام
كمان معروف ان من الصبح
يم
احنا في دير البلح واد الشيخ داوود فجر
هذا اليوم ما شفنا الا قصف بالاف 16
جيراني دار خالي بدون سابق اندار اجينا
نجري لقينا الدار مولعه وفحمه والناس في
ناس عايشين طلعناهم بشكل سريع وفي ناس
لحتى الان تحت الانقاض وما زال تحت
الانقاض قاعدين بنطلع لحتى الان في ثلاث
عائلات داخل هذا المنزل بيت خالي دار حات
بزيدان استشهد عدد كبير وما زال متبقي عدد
من الشهداء الداخل تحت الرد كنا اليوم ايش
صار
عندكم في الليله في الليله وهم
نايمين خبطو في بيوتهم وهم نايمين بدون
انزار بدون انزار خبطوا نزلوا العباره
عليهم البنات كليتها البنات والنسوان
راحوا اطفال عمرها بنت عمرها اربعه اشهر
خمس اشهر ولد عمره اربع سنين وبنت لسه قبل
اسبوع كذا بكتابها وبنت بتتعلم دكتوره
بنات كليتهم زي الورد زي الورد كلهم
نسوان
14 ولا منهم كل نسوان نسوان احنا كنا
نايمين هذا الكلام الساعه 11 ونص ما لقينا
الا الدار فوقينا ضربوا ضربوا تحت الطابق
الاول في كله نسوان واطفال احنا صرنا ننط
من طابق الثالث صرنا ننط من طابق الثالث
عشان ننجب رواحنا واحنا احنا عننا في
الدار تقريبا فوق ال 40 نفر ودار عمي حركه
نفر الحمد لله الحمد لله اختي لسه الجمعه
كتبنا كتابها والله الجمعه لسه كتبنا
كتابها الجمعه لسه ما فرحت ما فرحت والله
فستانها لسه عنا في الدار الدار فستان ولد
عمره ا
سنين
الحمدله ه